l'oeuvre n'a été achevée qu'en 1994 mais
elle accuse déjà le poids des années la
perspective de marta pan qui invite les
promeneurs à déambuler du centre urbain
de saint quentin en yvelines au parc des
sources de la bièvre présente
aujourd'hui un bien triste visage après
plus d'un an d'études le projet de
restauration pourrait se concrétiser
dans les prochains mois l'annoncé
officielle vient d'avoir lieu sur le
site en fin de semaine dernière
aujourd'hui il faut à la fois restaurée
réparer et concevoir des ouvrages qui
sont à l'échelle et pérenne et durable
le problème récurrent c'est le problème
de l'eau qui à la fois sa force puisque
c'est une force une part dont une oeuvre
construite au fil de l'eau et le lait
l'eau il est aussi le défaut capital de
cette oeuvre puisqu'elle a été mal gérée
on a presque trop d'eau une mauvaise
circulation et une mauvaise mise en
oeuvre de tout le système de fontainerie
l'eau élément principal de cette
réalisation mais plus globalement de
l'oeuvre de l'artiste d'origine
hongroise à travers le monde s'expose
ses réalisations monumentales des états
unis au japon en passant par l'arabie
saoudite
mais ici le gigantisme de l'oeuvre est
aussi son talon d'achille qu'on a créé
des ouvrages des structures et c est un
canal à l'échelle d'une métropole et
d'une capitale là où nous sommes sûrs
capital régional simplement coût
probable des travaux de restauration 3
millions d'euros le label patrimoine
d'intérêt régional décerné par
l'ile-de-france devrait permettre de
faciliter l'obtention des subventions on
a vraiment lancé depuis 2016 une vaste
un vaste programme
culturel de façon à pouvoir valoriser
tout ce patrimoine qui ont ce j'allais
dire petit patrimoine qui n'est pas si
petit que ça mais qui n'est pas financé
au titre des monuments historiques et
donc que les balles heureusement se
dégrade aussi et donc a besoin de
financement donc 12 cette création de ce
label de quoi célébrer ce moment avec
quelques notes de musique et quelques
mouvements de danse